[Musique]
bonjour Henry, tu te souviens comment tu es arrivé
ici, cette prochaine partie pourrait
[Musique] faire
mal à
toi et moi, nous sommes toujours
mari et femme, je t'aime
Henry
Henry, ils veulent ta technologie, je
ferais mieux que toi,
je suis
sur
altit Sho tire Sho p sur
Henry Henry riposte, vous êtes capable de
plus que vous ne le
pensez
[Applaudissements]
Henry, tout va bien, je suis là pour
vous aider, votre module vocal est installé
mais au moins nous savons que vous ne allez pas
bien  la bonne nouvelle c'est que
tu vas vivre un
moment la mauvaise nouvelle c'est qu'il y a une armée
entre toi et ta femme alors allons nous
lever ce soir je vais passer
un très bon moment je me sens
vivant woo c'est le  mur bébé je
m'amuse à passer un bon
moment à travers le tigre comme défiant
le Seigneur de
[Musique]
graac passant
par le
ciel pourquoi ils m'appellent
je suis TR
[Musique]
spe tu vas rester
là avaler  ce sang dans ta bouche,
tu vas te lever et aller le répandre
[Musique]
[Applaudissements] Le
leur à